good day in this extremely important day
in the life of Iraq and the Iraqi people
it's the beginning of historic
transition from the 35-year rule of
brutal dictator to new democratically
elected government hello I'm at Madera
kabhi in the next two hours we will hear
from Iraqis about this historic
transformation what voting means to
these people what Iraqis think about the
legitimacy of the elections and what
happens next in this country pleased to
be joined by Jim Hague founder and CEO
of spirit of America the sponsor of
today's program Jim Thank You Ahmed
spirit of America is very pleased to
present today's program on this great
day for freedom thank you for joining us
and I especially want to thank all those
who have lost loved ones to make this
day possible our goal is to present a
more complete picture of Iraq selection
a ground-level view from the people of
Iraq we also hope to increase the
connections between the American people
and the Iraqi people this is something
spirit of America is committed to in the
last year with the support of twelve
thousand donors we have been involved in
Afghanistan and Iraq helping equip
schools libraries and hospitals
supporting women and pro-democracy
groups spirit of America is a private
charity we have no affiliation with the
US government our work is a reflection
of the good will of the American people
we do what we do to help freedom and
peace prevail let me tell you something
about the unique setup we have here
today to review the election results we
have an expert panel we will have live
on the telephone grassroots
correspondence from all corners of Iraq
we have to bloggers blogging in English
and Arabic though report on comments
from Iraq and the US and finally a
studio audience will look on and ask
questions our hosts achmad elric ah be
spent five years as bureau chief for
radio free Iraq on April fifteenth 2003
after the liberation he was the first
person on the air in Iraq
first words from a tent in Baghdad were
welcome to the new Iraq welcome to an
Iraq without Saddam so please join me
and welcome the new new Iraq and ahmed
al raha be thanks Jim well with me is
today dr. Hassan a la tia is a director
of the Iraq foundation for development
and democracy in Baghdad and devout the
thumb bar the special envoy of the
United Iraqi alliance one of the very
important place in the Iraqi elections
and also mr. hasn't named the director
the director of documentation and the
Iraqi memory foundation welcome
gentlemen today's election of the
National Assembly is a crucial first
step anoraks democratic transformation
the 275 members of this new body will
now elect or appoint a new president and
Prime Minister they will also draft a
new constitution by august 15 on october
15 the Iraqi people will vote to ratify
this new constitution if approved on
December 15th a new election for a
democratic government will take place
this government will take control at the
end of the year or the now yesterday I
couldn't sleep so to truly appreciate
the magnitude of this day you need look
no further than the people of Iraq and
listen to the excitement and their
voices here's some raw material that
came to us via the internet just a small
sampling from a few people and a brief
look at celebrations in the streets just
before the election occasionally a
historic she shall i shorten probably
end up
khulna another in common we are going to
participate in the elections because it
is our national duty as you know we the
Turkish Iraqis have not had any rights
for over 80 years there are no Turkish
Iraqis being represented in the interim
government we don't even have a single
representative our rights have not been
properly given to us
Knobloch dining and then
and we would like to have free and fair
elections for the stability of the
nation and we would like to turn a new
page as they say for the Iraqi people
who have been oppressed for 35 years a
man in developed about the infinite
participating in the elections is a free
and democratic demonstration that Iraqis
are experiencing for the first time and
this is an unprecedented experience well
as I mentioned to my guess yesterday I
had a very long night I couldn't sleep
thanks to the time difference between
Washington and Baghdad I was receiving
all night phone calls from friends and
colleagues and Baghdad congratulating me
one word which I heard a lot yesterday
was happy feast and believe it or not I
was listening to the people in the
street saying to each other happy feast
so it was not an election normal
elections it was like a holy thing so
forgive me if I'm not focusing that much
now because I really couldn't sleep and
I enjoyed that night I really enjoyed
last night it was something
extraordinary and I think many Iraqis
lived and wish to see what happened and
in the last hours but also I would like
to ask dr. the Sun a lot to you how was
the last hours for you what did you feel
about less though when for the last hour
there was a blued to the TV and trying
to see what they are making out of the
story one point I would like to draw
attention to we in Iraq were afraid of
high expectation our optimism to be then
to be met with another false hopes I
should take this
listen to the great caution try not to
raise the expectation of the Iraqi
people to be realistic about it because
then now we don't know even the result
so the over joy is too optimistic about
it but the mere fact it took a place
that is by itself a success what success
has to be defined in relative terms if
you ask someone in Ramadi or Fallujah
what do you think of this and he still
lives in a tent like Fallujah here I
don't think he will be much impressed
with what happened if you are someone in
our morrow or basara it would be elated
that's a great day for him but if you
should speak to someone in Sadr City or
tower where he has no gas no electricity
no water I don't think he will be that
much interested in what you are saying
to the media tried to make a big deal of
this Iraqi had their hopes raised so
many times they thought things would
change that dramatically after the fall
of Saddam they didn't then there was
transfer of sovereignty people thought
that is the silver lining tend to be
false then they so there is a government
of a Yowie they said this would be a
real change it didn't take place that's
why many caution is very important as
many issues until father come borrow why
are you happy Oh delighted happy hours
just like my colleague glued to the TV
to the telephone and to the computer
screen I think this is a historic day I
think the Iraqis did a big blow to
terrorism in Iraq and two lemonade's of
the bath and Saddam's regime I think we
have to think of a plan and have we have
a lot of work in our hand good
expectation doesn't come without hard
work and freedom is not free obviously
we have a plan we are as a National
Assembly and as I representing the
United National Alliance the list 169 we
have a plan to first start to have a
Status of Forces Agreement which will
put
legal framework for the relation between
the US military and multinational forces
and the Iraqi government we have to
think how to have a lucky Britain all
the sovereignty and also a new security
plan and I plans to direct oil resources
and revenues to the Iraqi people oil is
owned by their like people not the
government election campaign is over now
so how I go to dr. Hassan named you are
of Lebanese origin but you were involved
with the Iraq issue for a while what was
your thoughts but what you've seen
talking to friends and colleagues in but
that in in the past hours there's indeed
a sense of elation a sense of
empowerment a sense of happiness and a
sense of over joy I think the aggie
society is entitled to that sense
although identity that we have to view
this event as crucial and as important
as it was as being just one step in a
long process and the under that the word
the word that said where the value is
that needs to be under land is indeed
the word process here we have here is
really the transformation that is of
extreme importance now the legitimacy of
the political of political governance in
Iraq is no longer going to be derived
from one person or from a revolution or
from a party it's going to be derived
from a process and this is what we're
seeing in in motion this is a process
that started with the fall of the regime
and we can look forward to its
culmination only when we have the
peaceful transfer of power from one
government from one elected government
to the other this is when we declare the
triumph of democracy up until then let's
be optimistic and let's see it
progressing we can be happy about what's
happening and everyone is entitled to be
overjoyed even but we have to be within
perspective will soon be joined by a
caller from Baghdad but very quickly who
do you expect to be the winner result
generally it's expected that the same
people who are in the power will remain
in power namely there
hsieh block the government I had a low E
block remember yes and the third block
the ship during the Nazi a bloke
definitely another here but the those
who adhere to the merge I to the Shia
religious agenda see the Grand Ayatollah
yes and then the the government will be
also a bigger block and the Kurds so as
a matter of fact politically the
political map will not change if you
tell me why because the kind of
electoral system which were adopted the
mean and the finance available to the
big parties give them the chances with
the absence of the Arab Sudanese who are
boycotting this election so actually the
political map will not change much the
fog all this is not a share this is a
lucky list we have very prominent Sunnis
on the less certain such a chef or as a
gerbil and what are shortcut and others
i think i think the winner really is
this is not rhetorical there will be
their lucky people because that's what
good about democracy democracy has two
main things first there will be
accountability a minister or prime
minister he doesn't do well the National
Assembly could draw their their approval
of his work and that could cause some
trouble and that's where accountability
comes and that's what lacked in the
current interim government the second
thing they're like people always carries
the final say the Constitution when is
written as a draft will be finalized by
referendum of the Iraqi people and then
afterward if you're lucky if somebody
does not form perform well in the
National Assembly he would be voted out
at somebody will be voted in in about 11
months and so and mr. Hassan and clearly
the meaning one can argue and I would
tend to agree that that the formula used
for the election was less than idea it
was one that that is that emerged as a
result of all sorts of compromises and
lead to I tend to agree to a
strengthening of people who are in power
or people who have actually the way to
get financed
however I mean what what one needs to
stress is that regardless of how we get
there meaning we get to the assembly the
tactical alliances that were created in
order to form those lists were exactly
that tactical and now we're likely to
see the emergence of a if you'd like a
reshuffling this is again a symptom if
you'd like an aspect of a healthy
political system reshuffling of
alliances towards including hopefully
towards including those who opted out
and in particular those in the Sunni
community I have with me Omar calling us
from Baghdad hello Omar hello what's the
mood in Baghdad Omar well I think words
like happy and George a very small for
him to use them to describe this day
this day is much greater than these
words frankly speaking I've never seen
so many Iraqis smiling as i did this
morning this day has proved the strength
of the Iraqi people Iraqi today despite
all the tribes of the earth and he
proved how courageous and her brave they
are asking optimism and joy and hope in
every eye in bed bed this morning so the
sound of bombs and ak's didn't really
prevent people from going to the polling
centers absolutely not I was walking to
the only center in my neighborhood and
there were loud explosions some are near
some our fault and there was gunfire in
many occasions but people really didn't
seem to care a little about that their
minds will all focus on reaching their
patients and testing their votes they
seemed even to hear any of
don't float it down so Omar white why
you think people behaved this way so
many people were expecting that the
turnout will be very low that people
will fear a possible suicide attack
what's driving people what's the
motivation of the Iraqi people to turn
out sir in such big level I mean of
participation well I expected a high
turnout month ago you know I live in
Iraq and I know my people the Rockies
have been waiting for this opportunity
for decades and they cannot afford to
lose this chance Omar thank you very
much we have another caller with us from
Baghdad it's mohammad hello Mohammad can
you hear me hi hello hello mohammad how
is Baghdad now well but that form of joy
and people are feeling proud of this
glorious day and the very steps that the
rocky people of the day did you have to
walk a long distance to cast your vote
yes actually I walked about two
kilometres to reach the bottom center
where your fright did you were you
reluctant or did you hesitate it to go
well I have many feelings today I feel
false feel joy I feel happy not only
thing that I didn't feel is the fair
today so what do you think what do you
expect from this elections will this
make when people hug here 30 people say
this blog to the whole ward
now they have to deal with that people
choice and the world war should support
and defend the new democracy in Iraq we
put our future in the box today and I
saw optimism and key of both bright
future so art rock will be a model for
the whole Middle East and region well
thank you Muhammad from Baghdad coming
up in our next segment a report from our
local correspondent who spent part of
her weekend with those voting here in
the US and by the way we'll be hearing
from many Iraqi voters here in the
States and in Iraq throughout the
program during our breaks here are the
first few stay with us we'll be right
back
yes
ok
from us
procure
if you come from
here in the US we've heard so much news
of concern for the Iraqi people safety
leading up to this election threats of
violence at the polling places questions
about voter turnout extremely heavy
security and so much more well I would
like to ask dr. oz hallelujah was this
day as you expected it to be my seat on
the security side I see that you are
others insisting on being over
optimistic on the security side not I
wish no no I in the security side I wish
after the fall of Saddam they took
similar measures to contain the country
and maintain the security yes the
security were so effective because
simply there is no cars allowed to drive
you cannot move from one province to
another you cannot across the bridge
good bridges are closed so in that case
actually there was a total care of you
if this is what the economists described
the democracy at a gunpoint this would
we have to do but this is has own
limitations and this tells as much as it
is good people well to the world but we
still have a big problem namely security
and then come the question where this
election will lead us if it will the new
Parliament will emerge a highly
polarized one big a block of Shiites and
the big block of Kurds and the
government in between with the Arab
Sunni absent this is doesn't augur well
because by the way by the election will
lead to trouble the Kurds had good bad
election 1992 not free and we at the
time we were over joyous I was a among
those was over Joyce about it but after
two years or a year they had civil war
and more killed killed concurred were
killed by Kurds so that's why I'm have
to be very cautious but did you expect
this level of turnout I don't know
exactly what is the level of tonight I
just came from back to the committee the
electoral committee I think
that's why doesn t % us know what was
expected and debate in Baghdad the
question was because this is the
American audience don't know it turned
out in a medical forty percent of 45 is
a great because then when he talked
about forty percent you took the shared
in different areas but in a newly
country where a new Iraq there the main
major component of the society should
take part in it if the curve will
participate seventy percent the sheer
eighty percent and the singing only
fifteen percent this is very dangerous
because then it is lopsided then you
feel that not everyone is willing to
abide by the rule of the game and will
not accept the end of the results so in
that case this is bad election but if
how do we are forty percent of Sunni and
fifty percent of here and 45 of Kurds no
doubt that would have the legitimacy but
here the big problem is especially this
new Parliament this job is to draft a
new constitution a constitution is a
contract between the component of the
Iraqi society so if you have a missing
one this is not good okay we have a
caller from na jeff weiner how much it
costs to call the US from na jeff and he
we will speak with him in arabic
marhaban al-aziz hello North Anna
channel cabin in an idiot laughs chassis
n KF Cal Atlantica battle infinitive I
will translate how was the elections
today imager and today energy of the
people are so happy because they do at
the first time and their life what they
want to do and they wanted to to give
their vote in the elections to what to
what they want and they like to to build
a new government in Iraq and the 000
thing and adjusted a people and the
families women and men are celebrating
because of these elections and all of
them are hoping to to succeed in this
the experience that they do which other
saint of the first time for a long time
they they prevented to do this thing
well yes dr. hassan a la tia is saying
that maybe we are over optimistic about
what happened today do you share his
thoughts or do you disagree with him
anyway I said you know dr. Hassan here
yes okay here go ahead I didn't hear the
question shall I ask in english or
arabic dr. hassan alotta samata can add
a cool animal roham alma shark and wash
your own free L&T hobart lackin and
italian limited to try to Valhalla in
ithaca Batna t-jet mata suniye Allah
hadn't Kabir cut atomic Havana retailer
Salima shinola aqui há del modo in
English if you can al angry hello I
think we lost over a chance to
participate and writing the Constitution
after the elections and after making the
National world this is how it sounds
when you call Baghdad or any place in
Iraq today well let's see what's going
on at the blogging disk I would now like
to introduce our two bloggers Michael
Totten and of the lockin deal who have
been leading and monitoring email
conversations in English and Arabic
Michael I was a situation there there
was lots of great stuff in the blocks
for today the election photos are really
popular in both the English language and
the Arabic blogosphere and I uploaded
some to the Friends of democracy site
and if we can I'd like to show
one of our photo galleries here so the
ink stain finger is looks like it's
becoming the symbol of Iraq's election
there to spraying it proudly and there
are photos all over the place of the
finger here like we're seeing here and
one of our correspondents in Kirkuk said
that he saw more women waiting in line
to vote than men this is anecdotal I
don't know if there really were or more
women or not but as you can see in this
photo there is uh there's quite a few of
them out that day and in the next one
this photo is actually my favorite one
notice the tier here in the corner of
rye and there's that finger again in
thousands of Iraqis they walk miles and
waited in line for hours to vote and
remember the whole time they were
standing in these lines they they knew
they were terrorist targets yet they
waited and they voted anyway here again
we've got that finger with the V for
victory yeah and here's a whole busload
of the ink stain fingers we've never
seen so many fingers in Iraq before no
and you know I I see a bunch of fingers
like this and I think of it is like it's
like the middle finger to the terrorists
and the end of rejectionist and here's a
great one that we found in the Iraqi
blogosphere Abdullah what you have well
thanks Michael some of the commentary in
the arabic website friends of democracy
net are one from huddle funny from
Baghdad quote the Iraqis are celebrating
today is the first national holiday in
50 years we are witnessing something
that today have we haven't even imagined
before they took to the polls today with
large smiles on their faces despite the
threat of terrorist attacks this is a
day that will never be forgotten and a
success for Iraq and the entire free
world also I mad and Sabah on a rocky
expatriate in Jordan said no I raised my
right hand today with great honor
and I told the Iraqi border patrol these
Iraqis are returning from voting at the
polls well thank you awesome thank you
Michael and back to my guests here but
before I speak to you and to father I
have a caller from NASA RIA zeyneb from
NASA RIA hello Xena Xena okay we lost
zeyneb maybe by from the mighty a nanny
caller from Ramadi please call us please
call us now back to you auntie father
was this day as you expected it to be I
think it's exceeded my expectation in
terms of how positive it was and I think
I was very impressed by I heard many of
my colleagues in Baghdad and all over
the country that one of the extremely
positive signs that the turnout for
woman was extremely high and sometimes
exceeded men that explains that how
they're like a society is advanced of
some countries in the Middle East who
even prevent women from driving I think
this is a great day and I think across
the board there are discrepancies in the
number of people are voting i think
that's not necessarily represents that s
only boycott or a sydney i think i heard
many stories of Sunnis and Ramadi and
Fallujah we're eager to come avoid but
they were afraid to go and vote they
were trying to come from the back door I
think it this this should be blamed on
the terrorists and I think even in the
advanced countries here the United
States we don't have all communities or
we'll all races will will will vote
equally there is there's a discrepancy
between white Americans and African
Americans and Hispanic Americans I think
this there's no doubt this election has
many faults and many problems but it's a
good start and the first they start in
the right direction this is the first
time the Iraqi people were able to make
their voice clear and they were not
heard before I mean yes the United
States of America
thankfully or move sat down from power
but liberation was not completed and
then came the occupation which was a
mistake and now we have election the
first time we lucky people could make
their say and you have this tremendous
of energy which is going to be do you
agree with dr. Asad that this elections
may lead to unwanted results and sell
point i think this elections everything
has to be a followed by hard work and
and and you know good work I think the
Constitution which will be written will
be the political consensus for Iraq the
Constitution in my opinion will be like
a political treaty a social treaty
between all Iraqi communities for a
better air lock if the same needs are
absent from these elections they could
come and participate effectively in the
writing of the Constitution and we could
have their voice in this constitution I
think the problems can be solved when
people have the best of intentions and
with theirs democracy and freedom well
thank you two for coming up next we've
heard about the violence and the threats
against voters for several weeks now
we'll talk to our panel about the
reports coming and today regarding the
attacks and security threats so far
we'll be right back
which is you know
hello Philip L prayed over it there's a
tubular for three feet long time
like this
Caroline cold months hutchinson
yes what
back to the sea rocky election coverage
and we have another call from Baghdad
hello Baghdad hello hello who am I
talking to I value from bike that I
missed your first name anyway how was
the security situation today in Baghdad
that the situation was no security is
very good it's very good in fact that
there is a less explosion Oh comparison
with a normal day before the election
but everything is okay and the
government take care about the security
well it's almost half past ten at night
now and Baghdad did you hear any bombs
or any explosions this evening after
this moment a little very little
explosion I hear it from here at my home
that's all nothing serious today a
couple of explosions yeah yet right let
dojin you can hear one or two that's all
okay how many do you hear normally I
here only to every night I'm not every
right justified okay so what do you
expect from this elections I the Iraq
people expect tomorrow will be would be
better from now and the government's
work will solve all the problems that
Iraqi people face it just before well
thank you very much wish you all the
best in Baghdad we've just talked about
positive news couple of bombs only from
areas in Iraq where voter turnout was
good and there weren't many problems but
there are also plenty of hot spots where
violence and threats of violence are
very real consider some earlier coats
attributed to Abu Musab al-zarqawi czar
vose war on Iraq Paul we have declared a
bitter war against the principle of
democracy and all those who seek to
enacted candidates in elections are
seeking to become demigods while those
who vote for them are infidels Zarqawi
pledges war on Iraq elections insurgents
in a town in central Iraq made a
gruesome billboard threat to behead
Iraqis who take part in the elections
back to our panel of experts again to
talk about the threat of terrorism who
is fighting the election now joining me
is professor Christopher Hitchens he's
an author and journalist and has said a
name from the Iraqi memory foundation
who is fine who is fighting the election
when did you last hear let me ask you
this when did you last hear the phrase
the Arab Street in the American media I
I don't know about the American your
time see it used to be used a lot it was
always we must leave Saddam Hussein
alone because if we ever throw him the
Arab Street will be inflamed or around
the world and it was it was a cheap
phrase for what some Western liberals
imagined to be a terrible Middle Eastern
public opinion well now they actually do
have something that is a proper measure
of Arab and Kurdish and Iraqi opinion
and the term Arab Street has disappeared
because what people meant by the arab
street was people like Zarqawi they
thought that he represented he
ventriloquist the true revolutionary
feeling of a of the Muslim world and now
they've been found out as false in this
assumption and I think it's a fantastic
fact so what's the risk of Europe's or
the test no street at all not even the
backstreet it's not even the gutter not
even the sewer underneath the gutter
this is this is fascism it should be
called by its right name oh it is so
called by all the Iraqis and Kurds that
I know it seems that they've carried the
day this means that we have a warrant to
arrest and destroy such people treat
them as the verminous enemies of
democracy and of popular sovereignty
they are and to dispel but this is
important to me as an honor our key to
dispel the quite widespread illusion
among many Westerners that people like
Zach are we really are the true
suppressed voice this is what's been
negated today seems to me the same
question is our car we now let's say the
biggest threat for democracy in Iraq I
would not or not discount the insurgency
that quickly and i would not pin it down
on Zarqawi alone this is regardless of
the fact that does a cow is what's in
the media sorry this remains a Sunni
insurgency but not an insurgency of the
Sunnis let's make the distinction
between the two this is to a large
extent what we have is the remnants of
the bath party of the Baath regime
reorganized regrouping reorganizing and
in alliance with the fringe of the
Islamists of the jihadists the tag
theorists those who consider if you're
not with us you're with the enemy and
therefore it's okay to kill you in any
case this such an insurgency has a
source of recruitment and the source of
funding and it needs to be addressed as
such it's not enough to be dismissive of
it it is extremely important to include
into what comes next into whatever
political process that comes next the
Sunni community in order to deny the
insurgency it's basically that its
victim which it is it is trying to
recruit namely the Sunni community
that's of course to me I just say I that
would be a more elegant way of saying
what i originally said myself in fact i
wish i'd spoken second but i wanted to
make a certain solid point for non iraqi
viewers as well because of this
prevailing illusion I used to have a
wonderful friend the hebrew university
of jerusalem professor israel sure
hockey was a great defender of the
palestinian human rights and when i used
to call him up every now and then he
would say in answer to my question how
are things you would say well so are
encouraging signs of polarization
because he understood that you don't get
any progress without a struggle
that these things don't come in a
straight line and they're never gifted
to you never come as a present now it
used to be said that said I was saying
represented the Sunni whereas in fact he
represented a minority of the minority
has sort of chick ricci mafia it I don't
think it could be said of mr. Zahawi he
represents even that he's a wanted man
in Jordan he's a he's a prison enforcer
a rapist a killer a psychopath it's not
even in Iraqi but there are members of
the former both the system who could
perhaps make a slightly larger clean and
that the point is that it an insurgency
based on a minority of minority has
simply no chance of winning and we ought
to be saying to them in as generous the
way as we can but I think firmly also
don't be the last ones to die for a
mistake well thank you Chris CNN was
reporting attacks at eight falling
places this morning at 7am there are
approximately 5,500 polling locations
across the country one area where
Zarqawi and the bath is showed lots of
activities is Mosul and this is where
we're getting our next call from Hello
Mosul hello am I talking to I am an
orphan northing bird oh so you don't
want to give us your real name north and
bird well that's fine that's fine that's
fine I told them okay okay so how is how
are the other birds doing and Mosul
aviary well what what happened today is
completely surprising how security was
was completely good though there were
some explosions here and there but they
didn't affect the operation and it is as
to the governor of muscle the people who
partook in the elections reached eighty
percent I think this is the very
surprising
how did he know it was eighty percent a
source from the time Kamya of Musel did
he expect this will be eighty percent so
we expect but we don't have any facts
now that it was really but it is very
difficult to to give an exact number or
an executive percentage okay but it is
around eighty percent so we know that
that these are car with people the
Baathists are very active in mosul you
know where were you afraid because of
their activity in Mosul our are we
talking about parts of Mosul which
witnessed this occupation and maybe
other parts didn't have the same turn
out okay let me explain here and
completely to to the last hours of
yesterday people had one opinion not to
take a take part in the elections but in
the course of time today they they were
sure that the security is very good so
that they started going to the polling
stations or centers and our why our the
number increased so that the center were
open a o'clock vanished and here
vanished fear vanished ok what time
people started to go what time the fear
vanished ok ok is from after 11am that's
a good time after breakfast yeah and
some rest
alright thank you very much muscle and
thank you very much for your call we
wish you all the best there no doubt
there is apart from the activities of
Zarqawi there is also the activity of
the bloggers very active bloggers and we
have contributions about the troubled
areas and what happened today in Iraq as
well Michael what are you hearing my
favorite comment is from an Iraqi
blogger he writes in English his name is
Hammurabi he wrote above what Hammurabi
Hammurabi he wrote our voting is no to
the terrorists no to the dictatorship
snow to hate and racism no to the
fascists no to the Nazis no to the
mentally [ __ ] tyrants so that was
the negative part and he went on to say
let them bomb and kill us it will not
deter us let them send their dogs to
suck our bones we care not let them bark
it will not frighten us let them see how
civilized to be in democratic let them
die by our vote tomorrow it is the magic
bullet which will kill them welcome new
Iraq welcome freedom and democracy
welcome peace and prosperity for all
nations without exception by terrorists
Hudson anything which was so interested
Abdullah sorry fell from the BBC website
a couple of people commented on the
terrorist threats all my ads from
Baghdad said our sincere gratitude and
appreciation extends to the entire free
world for helping make this election a
reality despite the terrorist threats
from many different angles we are
grateful that terrorism did not deter
the Iraqis from exercising their right
to vote also Ahmed Ali from Negev said
that the terrorists did their worst but
the Iraqi still prevailed they are the
supporters of Boneta and Saddam but we
are supporters of our freedom thank you
very much guys and of course stay tuned
we'll revisit the bloggers desk a little
while later or sooner if developments
weren't coming up to now next we have to
speak to the panel that's what's coming
up basically
you're reduced to that it's pretty hard
to follow that ham you robber blog i
have so what do you think of what you
hurts on the bloggers well I was saying
to someone on Friday and trying in a way
to keep up my own nerve my own feeling
that cowardice can be very infectious
and it was a constant drizzle of this
throughout the American media
particularly who's going to vote when
they've been told their family will be
killed as I said well and maybe I was
trying to just keep my own morale said
look cowardice is very infectious it
spreads like a weed like a like a plague
but courage is infectious too and there
seems to be enough Iraqis who said we
will go and do this no matter what and
that can the example of that seems to
have been the decisive one when someone
just said I owe from Mosul i think it
was i can hardly believe my ears
suddenly fear was gone I thought well
for your van okay it's not I don't feel
I've live to see it they've lived to see
it through all of this well that is it's
just I feel very honored i should simply
say to be in your company on a day like
this hasn't do you think that I mean the
results of today the fact that we didn't
see what we expected what many of us
expected many car bombs lots of
casualties you think that this day will
have any impact on the Iraqi mentality
in the near future at least on the
security side the short answer is I do
not think so because again this
insurgency has been operating on the
basis if you'd like using the same tool
that the regime has used fear and terror
rather than action meaning their attempt
that they have tried to terrorize the
population into not voting the
population ended up voting this is if
you'd like this battle has been won by a
rocky society against the terrorists
however it does not mean that all what
they have is fear and terror meaning
week we have to expect we have to be
ready for horrible events in coming next
on the part on the insurgency and it's
simply a question of that down the line
being able to overcome to break that
that
chain that the bondage of fear if you'd
like to really break it meaning one
example of what I'm referring to is the
fact for example I heard rumors whether
they're true or not does not matter that
the bath is are parading in uniform in
Baghdad again notice it might be
completely false the fact that the rumor
is there is simply meant to instill
terror so it's it's an incremental
process meaning as we proceed if we get
to the point of having that terror that
he'll dissipate that would be down the
line that if you'd like the real defeat
of ok we have a phone call now from
Kirkuk omar from Kirkuk wishes an Iraqi
city a multi-ethnic Iraqi city with
cursed Turkmens Arab and other
minorities hello Omar can you hear me
yeah I can hear you hello there hello
Omar how was Kirkuk today well actually
if everything was quite easy Inc
everyone was going to the elections and
there wasn't any kind of violence or
bumping on the street in Kirkuk and no
small fights between Kurds are obscure
commands no no no there wasn't even
there's a place it's called how we just
district in the country sidewalk was
filled with the people of the bus even
there the people there went to the
election it was something amazing so
even in those areas tell me what time
people starting to visit the polling
centres in Kirkuk we heard a one call
from Mosul he said it took some time
before fear vanished how was the world I
figure key 713 yet what it will that's
are the effects you expect i mean how
this election will reflect itself on the
situation in Kirkuk we know that there
are some tensions between the ethnic
groups and kook do you think that this
elections will have any positive effect
on this relations well actually it could
if the cut of their right and the
Parliament is going to make
some change for them and if the current
God gave places that they need in the
tournament it's also going to help them
maybe it will solve some of these
problems Thank You Omar from Kaku coming
up next what about the rest of Iraq
Kurdistan nature of the hope we'll have
more on what's happening there on this
day next so I know the polling site for
the east coast's was here in Maryland
and New Carlton now if you were living
in New York and not in Virginia would
you have come to vote if I don't have a
car if I don't get a ticket I'm a walk
walking on my feet coming to vote for
this great day and that's this day we
should not miss it and I send message to
all Iraqi people regardless of religion
race anything please don't miss this day
this is our freedom this is our day that
we prove that Iraq is being United not
as before that the Saddam Hussein
classified Iraq based on languages like
Kurdish are apart like they divided into
many pieces for no reason who are all in
peace one piece of track so please
racket people don't miss this there's a
great feeling
as she said Iraqi people don't miss this
it's a great feeling now to our panel
for a discussion of what has been going
on in other parts of Iraq we heard phone
call from Kirkuk Mosul we have other
parts where things were expected to be
very good like Curtis time for example
and i know you are an expert in the
Kurdish affairs for the Kurds I mean
this is not the first time they're going
for for elections but maybe first time
going in national elections you can't
just say that I'm an expert but it would
be true to say that when we were arguing
people are going to farted myself for
regime change in Iraq before it occurred
we were not just doing so as mere
idealists we were able to say it's
already been shown in practice and some
of the northern provinces that people
can co-exist together that they can
begin to create a parliament in the
constitution and a judicial process and
they don't have to waste their money
anymore and a parasitic army and a
parasitic oligarchy they can use the oil
revenues for reconstruction it's already
been done now of course there were many
quarrels among the Kurds in order for
this to happen and many disagreements
that are real and historic and I don't
think these are abolished even by the
apparent unity of the two parties the
PUK and the KDP but the the overwhelming
feeling first that they have a common
interest in no going back to bath is
impossible the road is blocked and
certainly not being afflicted by bin
Laden is among jihadism and second third
if you'd like more impressive they're
willing to say yes we are Iraqis we're
willing to take our share to vindicate
our stake in Iraq as long as we're
allowed to be considered Kurds as well
after what they've been through it
wouldn't be surprising if Kurds took a
sectarian attitude tribal attitude to
said we
what out of this they haven't done so
they've armed Sally for example risks
his life every day as Deputy Prime
Minister to democratize Iraq this is a
fantastic game present but yesterday we
were able to see in today and the
reports covering the Iraqi elections
there is a Kurdish over joy yeah and how
do you explain this I mean well we've
already mentioned that this is not the
first time they experience the elections
no indeed they've had their own but I
better me with first time I saw Iraqi
Kurdistan I went to her larger and and
Khalid iza and towns that have been
leveled and poisoned and destroyed but
you have come this far from that is a
good enough reason to be overjoyed
second to have demonstrated assertion
was a national identity and third to
have being able to contribute to the
liberation of the rest of the country
unfortunately I have to say as a friend
that I don't think there's enough
interest in the elections in
callistonian that there wasn't enough
controversy you know the parties all in
effect United there are some minority
Kurdish groups running on smaller
tickets but there wasn't enough to argue
about in my opinion it's based on prior
to our school to say so but it just
wasn't enough from enough of a quarrel
if you like what I like I think election
should be about polarization I like it
when people disagree in kinda sad one
thing as an anglo-american on Iraqi non
Kurt I'm beginning to get fed up with
this constant emphasis on sheer Kurdish
Sunni so I've known FB I've known it
I've never have known NT far for a long
time I've never asked him I have a
feeling if I did ask him is there a
sheer aren't or a Kurdish brother-in-law
or something cause of your friend he he
would if he said there wasn't he'd be
the first Iraqi I'd ever met whom that
was true I've never imagined Iraqi who
doesn't have an extended family so I
think it's wrong for the Western press
to segregate Iraqis in this way and I'm
pleased to see that even you in since
you've seen sounded surprised that there
wasn't more quarreling in Kirkuk about
these matters I don't know it seems to
me the Iraqis are at least has grown up
about ethnic and religious differences
and say Americans are but well I
differently now well we we are
somehow prices forcing us to those terms
and what was written about the 169 the
list which represent or the number of
the list of the United Iraqi Alliance
which you represent now this list was
accused of being a Shiite lyst supported
by the Grand Ayatollah Ali Al Sistani
and the rumor and the expectations were
that the south will give its vote to
this list is this what you expect and is
this what you think the Shiites in the
south did what well Shia has been
oppressed in the south and we saw that
from you know if you go to the south you
see the infrastructure in the South
probably tremendously broken and
dysfunctional it's very and you know
after 1991 when 300,000 shower killed in
a couple weeks in the uprising of March
that basically gave this you had an
incentive to become part of a new
political system and participate in
power I think if I think it said sistani
support to the slit does not mean this
is a Sheerness it's done here is
basically I consider him as an honest
broker not necessarily as a religious
man now honest broker between their life
people and politicians then I also I
remember before I came couple weeks
before I came actually a couple months
maybe a group of distinguished
Christians met sit with Sistani and they
were impressed because he told him I'm
worried about you since nineteen thirty
three this is Anna lucky issue is beyond
Shia or Sunni or Christian or cold I
mean I think Rocky's realized now in a
country that if know if not everybody
gets his rights and get their fair share
and power and resources this country
will never settle and there is a common
acknowledgment that occurred really I've
seen many cursor worried about the
situation and the South because that at
the end of the day will affect them we
are on one ship if it sinks we sink
together if it you know reaches the
sure we would save together one other
thing I heard about how the southern
people may vote and is that they may
give their votes to the Alawi lyst the
Prime Minister because he is secular
while your list has more religious
flavor and it sell it may bring people
with turbans to the power what do you
think of this I think this secularism is
an important terminology that does not
necessarily apply on a lark i think what
matters in your luck even if we have
religious party is we have a religious
party that do not believe in islamic
state or i will I it [ __ ] state and
that what matters the our list agreed
upon a very important principle that
that will not be in the next Iraqi state
the Constitution will not put a state
that imitates Iran or any other Islamic
country and that's what matters I mean
the the ruling party in turkey is an
Islamic party but it's probably one of
the best government's appeared in Turkey
and so we must not have this you know
you know secularism as a hurt on our way
I think it deserves to be said also that
dr. Chalabi who is number ten I think on
this list recently made a series of
campaign appearances across the south
with two quite prominent Sunni leaders
who he brought to the rallies to show
them and and the sheer voters that this
is not a sectarian appeal and I believe
that after the campaign rallies whatever
he took them to see the shrine of Imam
Ali in a job which has never they'd
never seen before been able to get to a
visit before was demonstrating in
practice that it's wrong to think
confessional e or tribally this this is
seems to me after what people have been
through and after the attempts to set
them against one another and after the
divide and rule tactics of the jihadists
and the Baathists shows an exceptional
honorable maturity well I know at least
until father's a secular person I would
be very surprised to see you're wearing
it's perfect nothing in 25 businesses we
have a cold now from the hawk from north
and a
rockets bhutan hello bhutan hello
serious bhutan barwani from the hook how
are you thank you for watching fine
thank you so really about well you sound
very good today here thank you and
what's the reason for that did you eat
well or did you go to the elections now
I'm very curious about the elections
hearing today in the hole it was a very
happy day for the people going voting
today it starts from seven o'clock kudos
I mean time yes Jimmy yes okay the hook
is we have their many Assyrians in the
honk so shall we expect the assyrian
list to be the winner there yes I see it
could be about the expectations will
come out at the results of the elections
and the votes but actually they are not
too much in not too many in in droves
city yes well thank you very much color
from the hook wish you all the best well
as we mentioned at the top of our show
we've got the studio audience here to
look on and to ask questions of our
expert panel let's go to our first
question please can I your name and your
question my name is Paul bussola and I'm
a resident of washington DC LaMotta be
interested to know what your your guests
think of the effect that today's
elections and the coming elections and
referendums in 2005 in Iraq will have on
Iraq's neighboring countries everybody
also I think I think it will have
extensive I mean every Arab country
neighboring country there is the that
you know leaders of this country start
their speeches always in this critical
time and because of this critical time
we cannot have elections and I remember
since I was five years old I here in
this critical time and continues to be
critical time
and that's why he has to stay in power I
think this is going to withdraw this
from them I think if there is elections
in Baghdad and kylo situation is much
better than Baghdad ideas from security
point of view I think there should be
elections in cattle and I think people
are going to ask for it and I think we
already seen some signs of it here in
Saudi Arabia and any Egypt and in many
other countries in that award people
start to question why can't we have
elections well I was very impressed
reading yesterday's round up of the
International iraqi verge of the
overseas expatriate road to see how many
Iraqis had voted in Damascus and in
other polling places in Syria and how it
seemed that the government had behaved
with some care to make sure this could
happen hadn't tried to interfere with it
now I have the feeling I've had it for
some time that the Syrian government is
on notice on this point it knows that it
has to dbar fi it knows that there's
restiveness among its own Kurdish people
it was a big democracy movement
spreading in in Damascus one of its
leaders sonica elezam was actually
quoted in yesterday's Washington Post
and it knows that its grip on Lebanon is
not secure and that there has to be an
election of some kind there too quite
soon probably this spring so though I
believe that these tennessee's were
already present in the region and in
Egypt and elsewhere across the North
Africa too I think it's unarguable the
successful elections in Iraq has given
and Afghanistan i would add and among
the Palestinians has given it an
extraordinary impetus further obsessive
there's nothing to quarrel with in this
interpretation I don't understand what
people are so cynical when President
Bush says this is the one region in the
world where democracy hasn't yet been
properly tried but it will stop being
the last week well we have another
question and another from the audience
please introduce yourself yes my name is
Greg Piper I write a blog at Greg Piper
com live in the area I was wondering
from both of you I've heard in the news
recently that the Sunnis might be
sitting out this election so they can
have more influence afterward once a
government does
come together and try to have more
influence that way if that is true do
you think that's a good sign that they
want to be more involved than they will
become part of an official government or
a bad sign that they are trying to have
more influence than they might have with
the people away from the ballot box
thank well I think I may have said this
before I hate to sound repetitive but I
have a feeling that the collectivization
of the word Sunni is misleading to begin
with we have no reason to think from
what I've heard so far that the Sunni
vote was so much request today either by
threat or by abstention we won't find
out for a little while but it certainly
was very much exaggerated believe I
already said that I have no idea having
no notified all this time how he
confession Eliza's or sectarian eise's
his family I bet you he won't say he's
just a Sunni or Shia I've hardly ever
meet narangi who says that about their
family there is a group that was and
there was an oligarchy there was an
oligarchy around the birth party and in
so here's the country that was
identified partly as Sunni that is going
to have trouble adjusting and I noticed
that King Abdullah of Jordan another man
who doesn't have very much to gain by
democratic elections is making pain
noises about the plight of this minority
but it's up to them if they want to be
identified with the idea of minority
rule they can but I can't believe there
aren't clever of people among the Sunni
Iraqis who've learned a little more than
that from the experience of 30 years of
war and revolution and dictatorship and
isolation and so far I think this
certainly issues being used as a
platform for to give terrorists some
sort of recognition to basically pull
the carpet from under the Sunni
community or those people live in these
areas and make it look like as if the
students are resisting this process
that's absolutely not true and Sunnis
who wants to participate in the
democratic process are double terrorized
and we have lost one of our leaders in
the Iraqi National Congress who is from
Fallujah for because he's for was for
democracy and was killed by some battles
in his area the fact is that that we
must not institutionalize this issue
make it look like this is the problem
the problem there are tourism and there
are certain people in Iraq Lebanon serve
the bass and Saddam is who was to take
over power and stay in power and nobody
else will share power them and take
people from their noses and take them to
the right direction and nobody can argue
with them and they're using these
arguments to you know to make it look
like a lack is a sectarian place it is
not like this unfortunately a lot of
Sony's in the Sierras has been
intimidated and threatened by terrorists
there for some you know period and we
discovered in the the first battle and
Fallujah an apple there are many
high-ranking Baathists especially from
the military line where she from Nassau
here and from bus while fighting in
Fallujah and leading the insurgency in
Fallujah so this theory does not really
necessarily apply and the only way we
can do that we can turn the table as it
happened now the other thing that the
terrorists were fighting occupier they
were saying when we now they are
fighting democracy they have to admit it
when we are morally clear when we know
what we want when we do that I think
terrorists are forced to say what's
their real agenda and that what made
them lose the time here by the way i
believe i was told i think reliably that
though it happened a little later in the
day than in other cities that when
people in Fallujah realized there wasn't
going to be any service intimidation
that a lot of them went out late but all
mass to the polls I mean I did you hear
this I was told that it was so hmm well
let's hear a lot of true would be a
tremendous reviews we have Muhammad with
us from Baghdad hello Muhammad hello
you've been listening to our discussion
what do you think about the Sunni
participation issue well I said that
from the beginning that there's many
people in Iraq do not want to buy or
give this election but maybe there were
under stretches from deters the group
who tries to
prevent the Sydney population from
participating in this and who expect
that the thousands of people of the luge
about fit in the election today but that
happen yes are you yourself a Sunni or
Shia I'm rocky right very good answer
Mohammed thank you very much here now we
will be back in a moment we'll have a
short break and we'll be back
very good advertisement they had
gatherings they had speeches plus the
the local channels that broadcast on the
satellite dish from northern Iraq had a
lot of good programs and discussions and
the explains in details not only the
Kurdish list they explained all the
Iraqi lists all the consequences all the
names and what they can do for her Iraq
and Plus don't forget that the internet
is very powerful and the community that
I am in touch with in the Washington
Metropolitan Area and in all over the
country because I have good relations
with the people in California in New
York in Michigan they are all following
up daily daily everyone is giving a
couple of hours to look in the internet
read the media and we read both sides we
read the people with and we read the
people against and we compare and we
came to the conclusion that this is the
best thing to do twenty-six thousand
iraqis living in the united states went
to the polls here friday saturday and
sunday in five cities across the country
here on the east coast coast the polling
station was in you Carlton Maryland
suburb about 20 miles from the center of
Washington DC we sent our correspondent
out to witness history being made and
here's what she found for most Iraqi
expatriates at the new Carlton polls
voting was a celebration voting
procedures for registered voters were
organized by the international
organization for migration
was precious day
my life
as I said most important thing
democracy non representation the
misrepresentation wraps spokesman Jeremy
Copeland was happy with the turnout the
atmosphere here is incredible people are
happy everybody's smiling it's a big
family affair almost an almost like a
festival people are just excited to be
here and cheering for each other over
2,000 people registered here at new
Carlton alone and across the United
States more than 25,000 and of course
around the world in the 14 countries
where we have the auto country voting
program we had more than a quarter of a
million people registered to vote so
what will he do to the ballots on Sunday
on Sunday when the voting is finished at
five o'clock the ballots will be
gathered in one central place in each of
the five cities across the United States
whether it's voting and they'll be
counted there by our staff and those
numbers will be sent to a Baghdad and
they will be released there some of the
Iraqis who voted today had bitter
memories of the Iraq under Saddam
Hussein Youssef Raouf and his family
came from Harrisburg Pennsylvania to
cast their first ballot on Saturday
dunno hishaku Lakota Winton an admin
they destroyed our homes many many times
they killed my brothers cousins and
nephews more than 120 of my relatives
were killed by the former government in
the Anfal campaign this vote is a symbol
for putting a stop to the genocide that
was witnessed so tell me about how you
feel it's your first time voting as a
liberated Iraqi it's it's really to me
it's like you fighting terrorists that's
how I look at it I look at it like I'm
fat interest today I don't have a weapon
that's my way I to fight terrorists and
it's excellent feeling I cannot spread
it something the word would not describe
how did you
well I am actually celebrating this
event because I feel today I'm
connecting with my family in Iraq we are
celebrating the same cause and the
freedom of making a choice no not being
being empowered and not being controlled
and this is what I am celebrating
actually today an Iraqi Kurds from
Kirkuk who has been living in West
Virginia for the past eight years came
to the voting poll dressed in the
kurdistan flag he was overjoyed by
today's event America zehrs olaleye
Mbakwe true yeah Nero today was the
greatest day in my life because during
the bath redeem we couldn't vote freely
and this means that you willingly have
your hand stamped to vote for justice
your nation and your country shadman
being black I hope that every honorable
curd would go and vote today for their
nation and their blue things but do you
have to anyway thank the overwhelming
feeling of Iraqi expatriates here is one
of celebration more than party politics
although ballots were complicated most
people told me that they knew exactly
what they were voting for they answer
dashi for spirit of America in New
Carlton voting centres and from you
Colton to Baghdad and David McDougald
who's the Fox News correspondent hello
David good afternoon good afternoon
David you've been organizing the full of
the Western correspondents in Baghdad
the convention center so you were in
direct contact with the almost quite
many correspondents Western
correspondence there did they change
their minds or did they where they
surprised by the results of the turnout
today well so far we haven't had any
concrete results of the turnout what we
did have was the Iraqi Election
Commission here giving some preliminary
figures know someone in some areas there
were as high as ninety-five percent
other areas done in the sixty percent
mark but what we're hearing now is that
those results were just simply
preliminary results from election Center
officials who were kind of guessing a
guesstimate game playing the guests from
a game of home how many people actually
were turning outside and there were a
lot of long lines and that that may have
pushed those figures higher in other
areas some polling stations were closed
some polling centers moved so it boosted
the the turnout figures and in other
nearby centers now we're not going to
get the final results they tell us for
another couple of days until we have
some more concrete results on how many
people turned out to vote but the the
correspondence here were certainly
surprised and pleasantly surprised the
number of people were turning out to
vote and we all think certainly that
it's a good thing for the future of Iraq
that so many people wanting to
participate in their own and their own
democratic process well this day and I
know it's been a bit difficult for
journalists to move in Baghdad today and
in other parts of the the country tell
me I mean how did you cover this thing
what were your sources absolutely our
main sources here in the Green Zone
where we've been covering and for
security reasons and good reason not
traveling around the country today our
main sources are just being independent
election commission the united nations
who are here and Iraqi politicians
himself we heard today from twice today
from the Prime Minister's spokesman iron
Aqib also we heard from a vice president
jafari he came in and spoke after
casting his bowl which he said was a
historic event for him when he'd
remember the rest of his life he even
joked as old as he was it was the first
time he'd cast a ballot so certainly
making an impact on on Iraqi politicians
today the the president yauger was one
of the first to kathy's ball very early
this morning so those are the people who
are are informing the Western
journalists who are stuck here who
haven't been able to move around the
country and really giving a lot of
access to information at six or seven
press conferences today with people
giving as much information as possible
and and certainly that's also another
good sign that the future of Iraq is a
one of an open media and certainly very
willing to answer all the questions of
the Iraqi media who came to these press
conferences
David do you think that we have some bad
things hidden under this over joy and
happiness today I think today is a
difficult day to judge that tomorrow
will also be a difficult day the real
judging time will come in the weeks
ahead when the the extra security
measures we've seen it over the last
week the curfews the vehicle bands when
those measures go away and there is
maybe a decreased security maybe a
return to not a sense of complacency but
certainly a sense of not being as secure
as we have been over the over the last
weeks in the lead-up to the election
that that's really the telling time
where the the Prime Minister's Office
saying today the vote by the Iraqi
people was a vote against terrorism and
certainly in the television commercials
we've been seeing it's a images of
groups of citizens facing up to the
terrorist looking and looking them in
the eye and staring them down and that's
when that's when this will really show
in the longer run when the security
measures aren't as tight as they are now
is whether the Iraqi people do stand up
to terrorism and whether they say that
enough is enough for knows they're
turning the corner and for a better Iraq
David McDougald the Fox News
correspondent in Baghdad thank you very
much thank you and here are some
headlines from today's newspapers let's
join our panelists again to ask about
how journalism on this story was covered
I me compares to what is really going on
did you read the papers today yes and
yesterday and every other day and I've
been a full-time journalist for 35 years
now and I I know when the press takes a
line or when it forms a collective
conscience or when it becomes a vector
of a conventional wisdom and I I can
just tell you if my instinct is worth
anything at all I can tell you from
watching it in Iraq and watching it in
kuwait during the war the build-up to
the war and since the the entire
majority of the Western press placed its
bet from the very beginning of this
argument on the word quagmire
and they've found it impossible to get
off it they the safe thing to do was to
predict failure disaster defeat in Iraq
and after a biddy became second nature
to people not just editorial writers but
reporters to inflict their stories in
this way and I'm afraid after a while it
became with some of them important to
keep this going because otherwise they'd
be proved wrong and then for a small
minority not included in mr. McDougal's
report he says everyone hopes this is
good not everyone hopes that it's good
at all you read Robert Fisk of the
independent a man who is very popular on
the American Left present who's an open
supporter really of the insurgency and
who says that the Iraqi people look
forward to the verb like the German
people look forward to the bombing of
Dresden this is what passes for analysis
and comment in much of the press now I'm
hoping that there will be of a really
decent reconsideration on the part of it
of a press corps that has regularly
misinformed us on this regularly
misrepresented this to us and which has
to admit that today's news the biggest
news interrupt for a generation comes to
it as a total absolute surprised no one
who had been relying for information on
the American press could have credited
what happened today only those of us who
kept in touch with Iraqis through other
means had any sense of what might be
coming so I think it's a fantastic
indictment of the press corps well let's
find out we've got what LA Times has to
say about this day we have with us Lisa
Rubin from the LA Times the LA Times
bureau chief and Baghdad Alisa hello
hello how are you all right thank you
tell me about this day what we are going
to read in the Los Angeles Times about
this day well I think I think we're
gonna read a lot of different stories
are about seven of us around the country
one well I think most of us are very
impressed at the courage that Iraqis
showed despite a lot of highly
publicized threats from insurgents
impressive people went to vote and in
large numbers it was slow in the morning
when people were trying to get a sense
of just how dangerous it might be and
then as it seemed not so risky more and
more people came out and we saw a long
line certainly in the south also
Kurdistan obviously had considerable
turn out the Sunni areas were much much
less well represented but but Baghdad up
despite predictions that there would be
low turnout ended up having quite a
large large percentage of the surprise
you voting were you surprised I was
surprised in some areas yes I wasn't
surprised in the south at all we've
heard consistently that everyone plan to
vote there and the same in Kurdistan but
a bad dad is very complicated it's
there's been a lot of threats here in
recent weeks people have felt very
precarious and I think we're on the
fence about many people whether to vote
they wanted to vote many of them but but
we're afraid and and the security
measures that were put in place seems to
seem to have I think largely work to
really make it a much quieter day and
give people confidence that they could
go out without being you know running
into a suicide bomber which is a you
know terribly frightening for four
people here so can we say that the LA
reports tomorrow will be a bit different
more more happy comparing I don't know
happy or unhappy but I mean I think I
think we all feel it was it was a it was
a profound moment there is no question
and it was a it was we were I've know
I've talked to some of my colleagues and
at the who are in different places and
where I am and and we were very moved
very moved well I Lisa from the LA Times
thank you very much thank you thanks for
being with us and now back to the
audience the gentleman here can't please
introduce yourself my name is Gordon
Johnson I'm a retired businessman in
Alexandria Virginia and following the
money I
a question about the the perils the
dangers of the oil money when it if it
falls in wrong hands if the not only
corruption but other were thuggery and
worse things that can happen with oil
money has there been any attention
during the election is there been any
bloggers of the newspapers is anybody
addressing this issue of the oil and how
to protect it so that it really belongs
to the people instead of not to the
government as their been talk of for
example a set-aside of oil money and pay
it direct to the people right away so
they would have a feeling of ownership
in the oil money and the government
might have to go to them to do get money
instead of getting free money which is
the way the government will work it
would be particularly bad obviously if
sacar we were to control the money but
even in good hands sometimes oil money
can lead to bad things I son from the
Iraqi memory foundation did you notice
any of this yeah actually I am aware of
discussions and our proposals that are
in circulation under consideration
within the in Iraqi political circles
for exactly trying to avoid the this
that the so called Dutch syndrome in
Lowell idea Ferrante's energy state a
state that realized not on taxation not
on its population in order to to get its
revenue but on outside sources of income
such as oil and for the time being
really this is not an issue meaning they
the corruption is an issue at all times
but with it where they got to oil
because the word production is not up to
the point where we need to concern
ourselves with that today however I mean
clearly proposals of the sort such as
passing the oil money to the population
and then have the population give its
mandate to the to the government are
under consideration thank you having
anything you would like yeah I've been
uh steve clemons I think it was the New
America Foundation
came up to my knowledge with the idea of
making Iraq into if you like a
stakeholder society by giving everyone a
a bit of the oil revenue something that
they could identify with as well as some
much-needed income you could set against
that the idea that will be great need
for what might be described as more
public or collective works of
reconstruction on everything from
refloating the marshes to rebuilding the
infrastructure the dams the schools many
other things and then of course there
would also be the question which we
can't avoid that some of the oil-rich
areas such as keokuk are disputed by
different kinds of Iraqi shall we say I
mean it's not completely clear and why
wouldn't want it to become yet another
source of bad blood if you like but
overall and what and astonishingly I
mean if the tariff terrible thing is
Iraq isn't drowning you know l-little
Illinois Ulm money it is barely pumping
enough to keep alive and so much of its
oil revenue was it seems misappropriated
by the United Nations blood for oil
program in the meanwhile that we haven't
got to the point where whether it's that
much wealth to so to speak distributed
but we have every reason to think that
he rocks proven oil reserves are greater
and probably probably better quality
than theirs of Saudi Arabia which would
be nice because another reason to
recuperate the Iraqi oil industry it
seems to me is to break the sound of
monopoly do you think cousin that the
oil issue was an issue during this
election I mean was it used as an issue
to attract the voters for example by the
oil issue mooning and I mean was it an
election issue it's as far as I know it
was not proposed as part of the program
of any list however there was talk about
such considerations I do not think it
was an issue like I should to go back
just slightly to the role of the media
because I I think that I do agree with
with the whole notion that the media the
media is an amplifier in office certain
sense of the so-called common wisdom and
once the common wisdom gets established
as being negative
as you mentioned indeed we get that
amplifier a cautionary note on the other
side I mean now this has been a good day
this has been a great day and as I
mentioned before I mean people have the
right to be overjoyed for today however
it's important not to have the media if
you if you'd like goes overboard in the
other direction and portray it as if
therefore there are no problems
everything is fine actually a lot
Rangers earth core what we're likely to
see quite a bit of if you'd like that
the grind of the status code continuing
what comes and any changes are by
necessity going to be evolutionary not
revolutionary I know that the word
revolution has been used plenty in in
the course of describing what has
happened today I'd much rather prefer to
think of it and to see it as an
evolutionary step rather than evolution
let their evolutions be something of the
past I think everyone benefits from that
there enough so doesn't the fact doesn't
go to the fact that a few months ago I
was being told by every studio expert I
knew every day every time I opened my
paper that motard asada was the coming
man the wave of the future of the
spokesman of the oppressed Iran I didn't
believe it a good reason not to know
that it was you know it wasn't true but
I was bullied by the idea every day I
was told would he is the leader of the
masses and now do they do it out either
pret yes some of them do some of them
wanted to fail without question I could
back with name you some names some of
them are so invested in the idea that it
will be acquired mar that they don't
want to lose their reputations by
changing the story and some of them are
just megaphones 44 frauds and worse such
as mr. Zarqawi who's politely called an
insurgent when he isn't even in Iraqi it
seems to me outrageous that this has
been allowed to go on for so long and
the the main let's not say the main a
salient point to me of these elections
is this ought to put that kind of stuff
to rest we will no longer be hearing
from the American press corps who is it
is not the spokesman for the ground down
oppressed Iraqi people they've made
their own choice on that and i hope i
don't believe that i hope and i'll be
there to try and make sure they're my
colleagues respect this decision which
they have not so far the new york times
edit
torelli called for these elections not
to happen I think this is one of the
better reporters the one you just heard
from I think I think the same was could
be said of her newspaper I better not
say that without being sure the general
line of the American press these
elections should either not be held or
should have been whispered that's what
we're up against so this is a victim
against the conventional wisdom in our
own country I said the Arabic press
definitely will cover this and will
write a lot of things about this how do
you think al Jazeera will be dealing
with this issue again we can I mean it
can be easily said that there is a
strain within our culture within the
Arabic press that does not wish the Iraq
experiment to succeed because I mean to
a larger extent because of our app few
as involvement in it but also for other
considerations however it would be
unfair for us to portray the era
pressing in as the bulk as a totality as
a monolith in that direction actually
even within al Jazeera and definitely
within the other outlets there has been
quite an attempt at trying to to balance
the if you'd like ideologically driven
view of anything that America touches is
negative okay by basically looking at
the facts as they are on the ground so
my expectation because of basically the
better than expected outcome that we
have had as far as we can tell up until
two up until now that is my expectation
is that the IRA press will also have the
role of an amplifier and we're likely to
see some some support some enthusiasm
for for what has happened although that
does not deny that does not deny that
the other strains meaning of negativity
will always be there they're more
ideologically logically driven if you'd
like them than being an empirical but
that there is it the scene is complex
meaning it I find I found it at times a
little bit as i said too unfair to have
a chassé unblock I mean dismissal of the
era press as if it is nothing but
negative about that is positive and
there is negative well let's move to the
front or the bloggers desk in any news
they're the last readers were friends of
democracy site if they thought Americans
really understand what is going on in
Iraq right now and I got a lot of good
answers here's one of them from a reader
named Rick sisson Americans who want to
know no Americans who are content to be
spoon-fed a five minute recap light on
the nightly news don't I watched a new
network news cast for the first time in
years earlier this week it was a potent
reminder why I don't waste my time with
him negative melodramatic doom and gloom
tilted toward defeat give me a dozen
good websites with commentary from a
hundred or more viewpoints instead I
could spend hours reading blogs analysis
press conference transcripts etc I
decide what's really happening not Brian
Williams great thing about a blog is
anybody can start one anybody can write
their own headline and the best one I've
seen today is on the Iraqi blog the Iraq
the model it says the people of one and
it's true they have Abdullah anything
interested well the headlines on the
most part throughout the Arabic internet
from sites such as al Jazeera and BBC
arabic generally described the election
as a success for Iraq and for democracy
a large one headline on al Jazeera read
the Iraqi people overcame the distress
of this election and await the results
of their votes however al Jazeera also
reported a week voter turnout outside of
Iraq another headline read the pessimism
of some Iraqi officials over the reality
of the Iraqi vision for democracy and a
third or fourth al Jazeera headline
described the fears of the Arab world of
a CIA Gaddafi government in power BBC
reported that today is a holiday for
democratic Allah it is a historic day
for it and the world a few other
headlines on BBC reported election
success despite attacks and killings
Tara did not deter her doc Thank You
Abdullah coming up next the future of
the new Iraq predictions and a glimpse
into our panelists crystal ball stay
with us
we as reporters me personally as a
reporter for the radio free Iraq have a
responsibility to cover the elections
today I met with the executive election
board which supervises the elections in
the hook and we receive the primary work
that the council has prepared for us the
election process is going very well and
we are waiting for the specified period
tomorrow God willing between seven and
five to cover the elections for the
first time we have free and democratic
elections in Iraq we as the Iraqi
citizens and citizens of Kurdistan are
very excited because we are seeing this
for the first time although there are
some terrorists who would like to stop
the elections but their attempts will
not stop us the elections will go on to
save a rock from this destruction we are
happy with these free elections we as
Kurds are not afraid as we have already
passed through similar circumstances and
we will learn more in the future God
willing I'm voting for the Kurdish
people who have sacrificed their blood
for their country and for freedom and
democracy God willing the Kurds will win
and make for a stronger Iraq yamazaki
the election process is the duty of
every honorable Iraqi citizen we need
the elections so we could have a
legitimate government that would help us
again independence from the American
occupation and we hope that it would be
a modern government that will protect us
its citizens
hi buddy Mahalo yeah the elections are
great that is the way to achieve
stability and security in Iraq and of
course we have to free ourselves from
the occupation because this is one
country and it should be independent the
voter would be choosing an independent
government that would achieve the will
and wishes of the people that is why I
am voting and I've got a shock with him
not Halle voting is our national duty we
have missed the political experience for
35 years and especially since we are the
majority sixty-five percent I mean so as
for me I'm voting how about we hope that
all the Iraqi people will overcome their
fears and try to reach the voting
centers and stand in the face of
terrorism and explosions and sacrifice
for this country which has given them
everything they should offer their
voices for the sake of erotica
welcome back we are joined again by Jim
Hague founder and CEO of spirit of
America to help us wrap up our program
by looking into the future with our
panel of experts welcome to thank you a
lot I'd like to ask you a question your
turn I know that your father risked his
life left Iraq because he was in danger
many years ago they stood for free Iraq
I know that you risked your life running
radio DJ that you've been under attack
and death threat and yet you're still
here you're still moving Iraq forward
trying your best I know why do you do it
why not take a better paying job
somewhere else with no risk well it's
difficult and simple do to answer this
this question but Iraq it's it's it's a
treasure worth hunting and worth taking
care of I have my roots there I have my
history there I'm proud of this place
this is the first place which witnessed
the first letters this is the place
where which witnessed the birth of
mathematical physics of all the sciences
which is bringing all this modern
technology to us this is a place which
gave a lot to humanity we should take
care of it I think it's it's our duty I
belong to that place and wherever I go I
will always be there I will always be
there at least for my father who fought
the previous regime for 235 years at
least to achieve justice at least to
make sure that before he died he will be
able to
see that justice was achieved that what
he lived for really happened the dream
he wanted to see really took place at
least for my father will do this good
and defied we have talked about the
potential and existing violence that
happened today in Iraq focused on the
threats to Iraqis and our listeners and
audience here today are almost entirely
Americans many of whom have lost or no
families that have lost loved ones for
this so for them from your perspective
is it worth it wasn't worth it yes I
think like my colleague Ahmed alack is
the cradle of civilization in this truly
Tirso and it's a great society is
diverse it's I think it's microcosm for
Humanities work and I think it's a great
thing to work to you know get democracy
like specifically when there's such a
bunch of thugs and killers in power for
35 years ruling this country bring it
back to the mid centuries and I think
also Iraq presents to me in too many
people as a great opportunity for the
middle east is probably the last
opportunity for the middle east to come
around and become democratic diverse in
which human rights are respected
individualized I respected and I think
as many people who did not follow the
conventional wisdom like my friend
Hitchens they were saying that II luck
will be the place where democracy will
start and I think we were you know we
were helping their lucky people to
liberate themselves and encouraging the
NSA's to help us liberate Iraq for that
specific purpose it wasn't for WMDs it
was because of the principles of
individualized human rights and the
future of the Middle East and Ahmed in
terms of those families that have
have injured or loved ones in America
what do you say to them well I think
they should be proud of their sons and
daughters their effort was worth a lot
I'm sure many many Iraqis will not
forget this contribution which brought a
different life to them it's not perfect
today in Iraq absolutely not it's not
the thing or the kind of society we
dreamt about we're going that way we're
moving toward that society we are moving
toward that country which we would like
to see it's not there yet but we are
taking the right steps and without those
sons of america and girls daughters of
america i don't think we could have
achieved this I know many Iraqis
actually who pray every day for those
guys I so old woman I saw old men
Muslims by the way praying for those
soldiers mistakes happen that
environment could drive many people met
it could put you under a lot of pressure
but at the end of the day what was done
was something which will never be
forgotten by by the Iraqis the fact that
the Iraqis are celebrating today this
could have never ever happened without
those American sons and daughters
do we still have more and Mohammed on
the line yes good who's that I think we
have no more Omar with this home are so
everyone knows amar is part of an
organization in baghdad called friends
of democracy and it's them who put the
many of the correspondence that we
talked to together in place so Omar were
finishing our comments today and I'm
wondering if you can tell us what you
and your family think is important for
the American people to know about today
well I think what happened they sends a
message to the world that those millions
of Iraqis who marched with all this
bravery this morning to the to the
polling stations are all grateful for
the people and for the administration's
of the coalition countries make this
happen I'm sure that the vast majority
of Iraqis appreciate their freedom the
freedom that they they they want after
decades of brutal dictatorship and that
those people appreciates the efforts and
the sacrifices and every single drop of
blood that was shed for the sake of
their freedom and what do you say about
the predictions of civil war are coming
in the wake of the election today no I
don't think that's possible in any way
what we fill this morning was direct
people standing united against the
threat that aim at destroying their
country Iraqis are capable of overcoming
their
differences and their dispute I'm not
expecting this these elections to be
perfect you can't expect the friction
from first-time elections but what I'm
so what why I'm very optimistic is that
this is not going to be the last and we
had election there will be other times
and we'll have the chance to re-evaluate
the situation and descend from the box
once again and to overcome all the
hostages that may appear well as we say
in the United States with elections
practice practice practice so the best
of luck to you thank you for joining us
today thank you drew and we want to go
to our bloggers to see if there's a
question for the panelists like yeah
I've got a question here's a question
from a reader and a fellow blogger who
goes by the name of the final historian
he says is there anything we as
Americans can learn from the experience
of our Iraqi friend Christopher do you
want to take that one well it's more a
question for American than an Iraqi I
think I used to say to fool the
intervention took place I was always
trying to point out to people that the
Iraqi and Kurdish opposition to Saddam
Hussein was in some ways during our
fighting for us we knew that we knew
there was a nun postponed able reckoning
with the sky down the road we knew that
he was a hideous danger to his own
society and to neighboring societies
will you he stood for the totalitarian
and the terrorists principle that he'd
have to be done with some day meanwhile
it was Iraqis and Kurds who were
fighting against him for us donuts we've
many Iraqis many exceeding many
Americans many rich people of course
have died for a rug but many Iraqis
Kurds have also died for our cause I
think what that means is that we should
cultivate and cherish our sense of
international solidarity and our sense
of the culinary the totalitarian
Charleston
and we should think of this day is one
of many one of many victories that would
eventually not just defeat but humiliate
and discredit that sign well yes please
I'm an Iraqi American so I qualify I
think the message is freedom and liberty
it what makes America have realized in
the world and the Middle East and the
idea which circulates in some foreign
service people or intelligence people
here in Washington that stability with
dictatorships comes before Liberty has
proven to be wrong mmm the only way to
achieve real stability through real
democracies and the only real friends of
the American people are democracies they
are not dictators America must abandon
their dictators and improve on their
democracy support in the Middle East
well I think it's a great note to wrap
up on one of the things with spirit of
America that we've seen in the last 12
months of our work is that in the time
that I've spent in Iraq myself that in
addition to the commitment of the Iraqi
people to their future what we saw what
we witnessed a day what a wonderful
wonderful day that the American people
as people as citizens not as the
government although the government
commitment is is so important but the
American people and their support of the
Iraqi people can make the crucial
difference and so in little ways in
large ways what we have had with a
mention we have twelve thousand donors
that have contributed to libraries and
schools and hospitals women's sewing
centers men's construction programs in
Iraq so the most important thing and one
of the most encouraging things I think
is that the American people can make the
crucial difference in this equation and
help the tough times which are bound to
lie ahead today is a very happy
celebration and it should be but there
are hard times and I think that the
American people can really make a
difference yes
Hosmer da well I think the today's
election is probably a reminder for the
American people about the importance of
freedom many Americans were born free
able to vote to run for elections to
travel to do whatever they want to
express themselves free and after a
while I think many forgot the importance
of this freedom and how much it means if
you lose it and probably it's a reminder
of their own history as well of the
early Americans who fought for the
freedom of this country maybe they learn
to appreciate the efforts of the fathers
of this nation of the American nation I
know the importance of freedom I know
how much freedom is worth because I and
many others with me were deprived from
this so when we have it we know how much
it's worth and it costs a lot so the
lesson or the message from the Iraqi
people to the American people is take
care of your freedom okay and on that
I'd like to thank everyone for joining
us today all of our panelists the folks
here are bloggers the blogosphere for
pitching in here and i'd like to
encourage you to help courageous iraqis
like these and those we've heard from in
iraq today when you have a chance visit
spirit of america's website it's ww
spirit of america dotnet and if you like
to help children help out with children
if women's centers and pro-democracy
groups are of interest to you you can
make a difference there so again thank
you very much for joining us it's a
great day for freedom and a great day
for Iraq